highly anticipated new court documents
in the Jeffrey Epstein case have just
been unsealed and everyone is talking
about all the luid details did you know
that Epstein's lawyer visited his house
on multiple occasions did you know that
prince Andrew visited Epstein's island
did you know that Bill Clinton it turns
out has a pension for young ladies
yes you knew that you knew all of that
you and I and everyone broadly knew
about every supposedly new revelation to
come out of the unsealed documents and
most likely that's all we're ever going
to know it's a limited hangout that's a
term of Art in Espionage and public
relations which makes sense because that
is quite clearly what the whole Jeffrey
Epstein drama has been about from the
beginning on I'm Michael nlls this the
Michael nlls
[Music]
show welcome back to the show a girl a
child under 16 claims to have been gang
raped in the metaverse this is the first
investigation of this kind by
prosecutors in the UK and I think I have
a different take than pretty much
everybody but we'll get to that in just
a second first before we move on from
the shocking Epstein Revelations this is
the most ridiculous one right this this
is my favorite one of all of them and
this was one of the little special leaks
that came out before the court documents
were unsealed just to wet all of our
appetite for the shocking revelations
that we all already knew headline in the
Daily Mail judge set to reveal disturb
in claims about gilain Maxwell and
Jeffrey Epstein by prince Andrew sex
accuser Johanna
scherg and here here here's the big
shocking new evidence that we were told
was going to come out and then that did
come out and that was supposedly going
to blow everybody's
Minds Miz scherg has previously claimed
that the king's brother put his hand on
her breast at the Manhattan home of
multi-millionaire pedophile Jeffrey
Epstein in 2001 Miss sherg now a
hairdresser 42 years old living in
Florida has previously said that gilain
Maxwell recruited her to provide
massages for Epstein in 2001 while she
was in college
recalling this incident Miss scherg said
in a deposition given under oath quote I
remember someone suggesting a photo and
they told us to get on the couch
Virginia one of the other girls and
prince Andrew sat on the couch and they
put a puppet on her lap so I sat on
Andrew's lap I believe of my own valtion
and they took the puppet it hands and
put it on Virginia's breast and so
Andrew put his on mine she said it was
all done in a quote joking manner
according to her previous accounts the
prince while being inappropriately
tactile had not caused
offense
whoa oh wow man so you're saying we got
this guy Jeffrey Epstein who is
cavorting at paling around buddy buddies
with every Rich powerful guy that you
could even possibly imagine all over the
world royalty heads of state Prime
Ministers businessmen he's got he's
taken them all to This Island full of
underage girls this weird pedo Island
and flying him around on his airplane
and it was all wired for sound so he's
got videotapes of all these guys doing
super creepy illegal sex stuff with
children and and the big shocking
Revelation is
that prince Andrew
touched a girl who was of age who is
clearly over
18 while she sat on his lap of her own
valtion and it was all done in a joking
Manner and did not cause
offense
wow cool story bro it's nothing that's
nothing it's not what what is being
alleged here is not illegal
obviously it's not even by today's
standards particularly inappropriate not
saying it's you know the the way a man
ought to behave but by today's
standards that that's almost wholesome
are you kidding me that's the obviously
there is so much more to know about all
of the clients what do we know we know a
handful of Jeffrey Epstein's clients by
name but we know that there were many
many others who were extremely powerful
who are they we know that they were
doing super creepy things with underage
girls let's hear about those incidents
we know that there were cameras in all
the rooms where are the
tapes oh we don't get get any of that we
just get a slightly embarrassing episode
about prince Andrew that we already knew
cool cool man when are we going to get
significant information about Jeffrey
Epstein uh sounds like probably on the
31st of February 20 never that's when
we're going to get that information it's
never going to come out and the only
reason they're making a big hubbub about
the the unsealed documents now is to
distract everybody with a limited
hangout which which is a term of Art in
Espionage which is clearly what was
going on in on Epstein's Island and in
his townhouse and on all of his
properties and it's a term of art in
public relations and crisis
Communications which is what's going on
here too totally ridiculous Mike
cernovich put this very well his his
take on Epstein is the same take that
I've been advancing for a long time in
fact it what's funny about the timing of
all this is right before the new year I
was asked to make my predictions my NL
stradamus predictions for the new year
and my final one was we're not going to
get any significant new information on
Jeffrey
Epstein we're not we're not going to
really find out The Client List we're
not going to learn anything and then the
next day right after I filmed that
headlines we're g to see all the
unsealed Epstein documents I said oh
darn maybe I was wrong I said no I
wasn't wrong this is totally fake news
this is going to be a total fake news
distraction and it turns out I was
totally right what Mike cernovich said
here was that years ago back in
2017 his lawyer was working on a freedom
of the press case and it was a
defamation case and Epstein wasn't the
defendant but it kind of involved
Epstein so this goes on they're filing
all these cases in court cernovich says
hundreds of thousands of dollars later a
trip to the second Circuit Court of
Appeals and a lot of fighting we had a
batch of documents ready to be unsealed
the weekend before the documents were
made public the southern district of New
York arrested Epstein
quietly when he landed his private jet
on an airport from a trip he took in
France no perw walk for Jeffrey Epstein
he goes on to say the indictment against
Epstein does not charge anyone except
Epstein and there's nothing to indicate
that anyone who flew to Epstein's
private island has faced
scrutiny because the southern district
of New York charged the lowest level
offenses possible they quote lacked
jurisdiction to raid Epstein's Island in
little St James
as well as his New Mexico and Paris
properties those houses were left
unattended for a couple of weeks during
that time a safe went missing well
that's kind of weird how did a safe go
missing in Jeffrey Epstein's properties
what would have been in that safe he had
a lot of lued stuff a lot of valuable
stuff just sitting out so what was
whatever was in the safe had to be very
very valuable we know that the
properties were totally wired with
cameras and microphones we know they
were recording extremely powerful people
do doing extremely illegal and
embarrassing things we we we I think can
deduce that what was in the safe was
compromise during the gilan Maxwell
trial cernovich points out it was
reported that evidence from Jeffrey
Epstein's safe went
missing after a raid by the FBI
H well
then I don't care who showed up to
Epstein's Island to do what really I
care a little bit it'd be good for
people to be brought to
Justice the thing that everyone is
talking about I don't really care about
o did you hear this lawyer showed up and
did the oh look prince Andrew groped a
21y
old okay wow stop the
presses the question that interests me
is who was all of this in service
of where did all that money come
from where where did all these
properties come from
why were the properties wired for
sound why why were there cameras
everywhere what was in that
safe who has the contents of the safe
now who was the contents of the safe
made
for that's what I want to know we know
that gilain Maxwell's father was a spy
we know that he was mobbed up with
Israeli intelligence Russian
intelligence and British
intelligence we know we already knew
that Jeffrey Epstein had a relation to
American intelligence we know this
because Alex aasta who was the US
attorney Prosecuting Jeffrey Epstein
back in Florida uh while he was being
interviewed to be Trump's labor
secretary said that in order to explain
why he put the kid gloves on for Jeffrey
Epstein he said oh I was told from up
above that Jeffrey Epstein belonged to
intelligence so now I think we got
pretty good good uh reason to believe
that he had a relationship with American
intelligence because his safe went
missing when the FBI rated that
okay what was this
thing what was the Epstein operation
obviously some kind of intelligence
operation what was it and who was it for
that's what I want to know by the way
I'm not suicidal just just letting you
know I want to put this out there right
now I am not suicidal I've I'm I've not
had Suicidal Thoughts
not just asking a question okay now
speaking of life and death you ought to
check out pre-born right now go to
preborn dcoms last year because of you
preborn network of clinics saved over
58,000 babies thank you to all who made
this possible we need to celebrate these
precious babies when Charlotte found out
she was pregnant she was 7 weeks along
in the back of her mind she thought
abortion was the best solution she went
into a pre-born clinic and after hearing
her baby's heartbeat and seeing her
beautiful baby on ultrasound she chose
life my name is Shan I just want to
share a little experience with you
through my pregnancy I am 32 weeks
pregnant when I found out I was pregnant
I was 7 weeks um my pregnancy was an
unplanned situation I was unplanned but
my boyfri and he always needed a child
and abortion was in the back of my mind
but I know if I I did it that would ruin
my relationship but doing my first Ultra
song seeing my baby girl moving and here
in the heartbeat it was so overwhelming
it was a joy for us both of us were
happy we're excited we can't wait to
welcome our baby girl into this world
and I want to thank mission pre-born for
the h song I thank you for everything
that you done that you have done for us
thank you so much and God bless you her
heart is filled with gratitude for all
of you who made this possible just 28
bucks a month can be the difference
between the life and death of a child
when a mother meets her baby on
ultrasound and hears that heartbeat it
is a Divine connection that doubles a
baby's chance at life let's join
together help mothers choose life to
donate dial pound 250 say keyword baby
that's keyword baby or go to pre-born
dcoms can
wle pre-born fundraises separately for
all the administrative costs so every
dollar you get go straight towards
saving babies go to preborn
docomo wle and donate right now a lot of
men feeling a lot of discomfort right
now with the questions that are being
asked and the evidence that could
theoretically come to light in the
Jeffrey Epstein case now speaking of
making men uncomfortable the new lady
director of whatever The Next Star Wars
movie is going to be just gave a talk I
guess was being interviewed by John
Stewart at a panel called women in the
world and she said that her goal for the
next Star Wars movie is to make a really
entertaining and beautiful movie that
everyone's going to enjoy just kidding
what she said was her goal is to make
men feel
uncomfortable what is the balance of
activating a force for
change but also trying
to permeate that patriarchy that power
structure and is that a part of the
calculation of your art as well and and
what's been the reaction to that oh
absolutely um I like to make men
uncomfortable I enjoy making men
[Applause]
uncomfortable not you just
just taken Point
Tak but um you know it is important to
be able to look into the eyes of a man
and say I am here and recognize that and
recognize that I am working to bring
something that makes you uncomfortable
and it should make you uncomfortable
because you need to change your attitude
and it's only when you're uncomfortable
when you're Shifty when you have to have
difficult conversations that you will
perhaps look at yourself in the mirror
and not like the
reflection so this clip is from some
years ago this lady's name is sh mean
Obed chinoi and it's coming to the
Forefront now because she's directing
whatever The Next Star Wars movie is and
everyone is rightly concluding from this
that The Next Star Wars movie is going
to be terrible that's been true of
pretty much all the Disney Star Wars
movies there was that one exception what
was it Rogue one I think was okay but
the rest of them have been just
absolutely unbearably bad and the next
one is probably going to be even worse
but everyone's just making fun of her
and saying she's a crazy feminist and
she's going to ruin Star Wars which was
ruined many years
ago she does have a point she does have
a point she says I want to make men
uncomfortable men need to feel
uncomfortable and I think that's true
not in the way that she intends it but I
think it's true she thinks that men are
uncomfortable because they've never
never given their power away to women
men are uncomfortable because they've
never accepted feminism men are
uncomfortable because they're living as
the beneficiaries of the patriarchy
that's all fake news that's all
completely ridiculous the opposite is
true and and that is why men need to
feel uncomfortable men feel discomfort
wielding
power this goes all the way back to to
chapter three of the Book of Genesis
when Adam and Eve sin and God tells them
what their punishment is going to be and
their punishment is in a way a blessing
because God is equipping man and woman
to live in the Fallen World he's
preparing them for that and he says to
Eve he says to the woman your desire
will be for your man but he shall rule
over
you men contrary to what feminists think
don't actually want to Lord over women
they don't want to they don't want to be
knuckle dragging you know screaming
barking orders everywhere making every
single decision just just uh bossing
everyone around that's not What Men
actually want you know what men actually
want men want to sit on the couch and
eat potato chips and be left alone
that's that is what men would do if we
had our
DRS it is a total lie of feminism that
we want to be just stomping around
barking orders at at everybody that's
not what men want to do we don't want to
make every decision we don't want to
have all the responsibility we don't
want the weight of a household and a
family on our shoulders we just kind of
want to be left alone that's our that's
our at least base appetite to be
resisted well we have to do what we are
called to rise up to do is be
responsible and make decisions and take
take
accountability and and that's what men
need to do now men part of the reason
that we have a lot of social dysfunction
is because men won't act like
men men feel uncomfortable acting like
men so we seed every responsibility to
women so so we act like women so in some
cases we chop ourselves up and try to
pretend to be women that's not good do
you do you really think that the
problems the social problems of America
in the year of Our Lord
2024 are that men are too masculine men
are are are too manly these days are you
kidding me give me a
break if social problems have increased
over the last 50 years as I think we
would all have to agree they
have over that period have men become
more manly or less manly have men become
more patriarchal or less patriarchal
have men become more feminist or less
feminist the answers are very very clear
I totally agree with what's her face
charmine OB
chinoi men need to be made to feel
uncomfortable and the thing that makes
men most uncomfortable these days is
acting like men and taking
responsibility and wielding the just
power with which we have been entrusted
for most of History
we feel less comfortable with that than
ever and to quote Don Corleone from a
good movie unlike some of these bad
movies that have been coming out from a
good movie tells Johnny fontain what do
I what do I do I don't know what to do
Godfather I you can act like a man
what's the matter with you what's the
matter with you speaking of men and
women and perhaps unexpected opinions
there is a really weird Story coming out
of the
UK police are investigating the first
case of rape in the metaverse the
metaverse is just the video game world
that Mark Zuckerberg wants us all to
live in you put on the goggles and it's
a totally immersive kind of video
game according to prosecutors a child a
girl under the age of 16 was attacked in
a virtual reality video game and she was
left distraught after her Avatar was
gang raped by strangers
online now the report goes on to make
clear that the girl did not suffer any
physical inj obviously she's just
wearing a headset in a video game but
prosecutors say she suffered emotional
injuries and they're going to
investigate this as some kind of sexual
crime and a lot of conservatives are
making fun of this they're saying are
you kidding me she should have just
taken the headset off are you kidding me
it's just a video game grow up are you
kidding me she doesn't have any physical
injuries so it's there's no crime took
place to which I
say that's the most liberal take I've
ever heard are you kidding me of you you
think that the only kind of crime that
can take place is a physical crime you
think that what we do
online is is morally neutral that we
shouldn't be held accountable for what
we do on are you kidding that's what the
libs think that's not what the
conservatives think absolutely these
guys should be investigated I'm not
saying it's identical to
rape but it's not totally dissimilar why
is rape bad rape why why is rape a a
more serious crime than
any other kind of physical assault if if
rape were just about the body if if if
human life were just about the physical
then a sexual assault would be no
different from any other kind of assault
right the reason it's so much worse is
because we're not just bodies we're
Souls we have psyches we have emotions
we have souls we value things like
integrity and modesty and virtue and a a
a a violation a sexual violation is more
severe it cuts more deeply at the human
person than if someone just came up and
punched you in the face or cut you on
the
wrist we're talking about a little girl
here you know if if these guys were just
discovered to have
texted inappropriate messages to a let's
say I don't know how old a girl is but
let's say she's 12 or 13 if if these
guys were found to have texted in
inappropriate sexual messages at her I
think everyone would agree they should
be investigated and probably prosecuted
so why is it any different if it happens
in a video game where instead of texting
words instead of the symbols being
letters and words the symbols are
characters enacting all of these gross
obscene things on the Avatar of a little
girl the reason I think this is
important is there is a view that has
prevailed on the left and on the right
that whatever the law says in the in the
physical world in the real
world we shouldn't be held accountable
for anything we do online
online is just the wild west do whatever
you want that's a that's a bad situation
that has allowed all sorts of terrible
things to proliferate lots of online
crimes uh obviously the the now ubiquity
of
pornography you know sexual acts that
you would would never tolerate in the
real physical world everyone is allowed
to indulge in and encourage to indulge
in online all the time uh Vicious Kind
of speech to one another vicious often
threatening sometimes illegal speech we
just encourage that you would never talk
to someone in real life the way you talk
to someone on
Twitter online it doesn't
matter I think anything that that allows
us to recognize that what we do
online is real is is a very good thing
and I think the girl probably is
somewhat scarred maybe not quite as much
as if she were attacked in the physical
world but totally immersive virtual
reality is a pretty close simulacrum
especially for people who aren't fully
developed go investigate these guys at I
mean there's also this question why was
she even playing the video game in the
first place where were her parents who
did these guys know she was a kid maybe
not you're just talking about little
avatar characters but
nevertheless investigate this put put
some guard rails on this if if someone
is living in the metaverse for let's say
an hour a day two hours a day four or
five hours a day and they're behaving
like a total Sater criminal psychosexual
stist and then they take off the goggles
and they go out to the real world our
modern liberal culture says well we can
easily compartmentalize those things but
any serious study of human nature says
no you can't because you're crafting
your very desires your behaviors your
your way of viewing the world your way
of viewing women your way of viewing
people your way of viewing yourself in
the world you're crafting all of that
with how you spend your time how you
fantasize how you engage even if it's in
virtual
reality and that you're not going to be
able to just totally cut that off once
you reenter into the real the so-called
real world I'm beginning to think the
the conservatives the you know the
church ladies they were totally right
about violent video games in the 90s
they were just a little too soon because
in the 90s you're talking about Mortal
Kombat everyone knows that's not reality
well now when you throw on the metaverse
goggles the line between reality and
video games is a lot blurrier and it can
do uh play a lot more tricks on your
psyche and your emotions and your
desires as we see here from the way this
SC
I think rightly claims to be
victimized now is the perfect time for
your family to discover bent key an
entirely new streaming platform for kids
entertainment created by the daily wire
bent key is dedicated to telling
Timeless stories that kids will love and
parents can trust all 100% adree with
thousands of downloads and festar
reviews bent key is a favorite for
parents grandparents and teachers who
believe their kids deserve the best plus
new episodes are released every Saturday
we brought back Saturday morning morning
cartoons if you have a daily wi Plus
Membership you already have access to
Bent key if you are not a member this is
your invitation to try bent key for free
that is right we're giving everyone a
free 14-day trial of Premium kids
content at benkey go to Bent key.com use
code unlock to sign up and start your
trial
today speaking of pouncing on
women the Associated Press is
reporting that Harvard's president's
resignation highlights new conservative
weapon against
colleges plagiarism that's the new
conservative weapon we developed it in
our conservative
biolabs you know our conservative
armories we said oh yes here it is the
new weapon that we're going to wield
against the left and the weapon is
called their own actions that's we're no
we invented that we invented plagiarism
you see plagiar no one ever cared about
plagiarism before for but now these
these cynical bad faith conservatives
have decided that it's wrong to steal
other people's academic work in
scholarship this is the the most serious
academic crime you could commit and has
been forever for the entire history of
scholarship but now the AP says no he's
conservatives they just invented that so
I love the community notes on this
post say uh actually plagiarism is a
breach of rules for Harvard University
claudian gay was ultimately forced to
resign for a series of breaches of this
policy plagiarism or application of the
rules around plagiarism therefore cannot
be considered a weapon yeah yeah I love
that of course totally ridiculous the
reason I even mentioned the stupid AP
headline conservatives pounce the reason
I mention it is because it shows you
that the libs are taking this hard
there's been some debate is this really
a win the new president of Harvard or or
the interim president is another huge
lib so is that really a win uh I don't
know this woman Claudine gay is going to
retain her faculty position at Harvard
which is insane she had two jobs faculty
and president if you get caught
plagiarizing the last job you should be
able to keep is the faculty job the last
job you should be able to keep is the
academic job right it's to she violated
the ultimate rule of Academia if she's
going to lose one of the jobs it should
be the faculty job she really should
lose both of them but they're going to
give her this nice parachute she's going
to get to keep her faculty job and she's
going to get to keep her president's
salary So This Woman's still going to
make $900,000 a year we don't know the
exact figure but it's somewhere around
there at least maybe
more so we say hold on Harvard gets a
new liberal
president this woman gets to keep almost
a million bucks a year and her s ofure
at
Harvard how is this a win not saying
it's perfect but
the left is feeling the pain on this the
left thinks this is a loss the
Associated Press thinks this is a
loss mark Lamont Hill who is a uh black
activist left-wing professor and uh
political
pundit he was Furious when this came out
when when Claud and gay resigned he
tweeted out he
said the next Harvard president must be
a black woman so then some of us
conservatives started suggesting all
sorts of black women who would be good
some were I think jokingly suggesting
Candace Owens uh I I suggested Carol
Swain who actually would be a great
choice one because she Rose to the very
Heights of the academic field she's a
woman who came from nothing she grew up
in a shack without running water she
Rose to the very Heights of Academia she
became a tenur professor of Princeton
and she won the American Political
Science associations woodro Wilson award
which is the top prize in political
science she's a very inspiring very
impressive woman and then she thought
for herself and contradicted liberal
Orthodoxy so they tried to boot her out
she was a tenur professor she ended up
back at Vanderbilt they hated her there
too because she thought for herself but
her scholarship was apparently good
enough for Harvard standards because the
former president of Harvard plagiarized
Carol Swain so she would be a great
choice but people were suggesting all
sorts of of black women and Mark Lamont
Hill this same left-wing academic and
black activist uh pundit he responded to
someone who suggested Candace and said
this is the problem y'all really think
black people are
interchangeable now now he sent that he
sent that tweet at about
800m on January
2nd 7 hours prior he sent the first
tweet he said the next president must be
a black woman okay how about this black
woman y'all think black people are
interchangeable how dare you no you man
you just said it I didn't say it well
that was the quickest defiant L I've
ever seen
you you they must pick any black woman
it doesn't matter who they're all
completely interchangeable all right
well how about this one you how dare you
you dirty rotten white man white devil
racist you think they're
interchangeable what just cuz I told you
so yeah I guess so I don't know man they
feel hurt by this is what I'm saying the
libs however they're trying to to put on
a brave face here are Furious they TR
they when they got the plagiarism accus
against the Harvard president they
covered them up immediately they lied
about them they tried to push them to
the side and finally the political
pressure was too
tough they had to let her go and they're
whining and crying about it it's a win
it's a win even though she gets to keep
her her almost million bucks a year the
reputation of Harvard has been
damaged the donor dollars to Harvard are
going to decrease I mean that really
started this isn't really about
plagiarism this is because claudian gay
and the former president of upen
both testified before a congressional
committee and said that calls on campus
for genocide against the Jews didn't
necessarily constitute harassment so
what this is really about is an
accusation of anti-Semitism that's
what's underlying all of this but the
white lady from Penn immediately gets
fired the black lady from Harvard
doesn't immediately get fired because
that would be politically incorrect so
conservatives wisely recognize Dr she's
weak donors are very upset about the
Israel thing so this is a good
opportunity to press the issue
plagiarism was a good issue to use it is
legitimately the most serious academic
crime this woman was weak she was
completely unqualified to be the Harvard
president so it was it was a an
opportunity for conservatives to exploit
multiple weaknesses and that's a good
thing that's just called politics folks
the the libs are trying to say that
Chris rufo and the conservatives who are
really responsible for this are bad
faith actors because they were
exploiting weakness is exploiting
weakness that's just politics they
didn't they didn't write the the
plagiarized accounts they didn't they
didn't plagiarize claud's PhD thesis and
all a lot of the rest of her poultry
academic output they didn't give her 11
published scholarly articles by the time
she became president of Harvard 11
that's what a that's what a graduate
student should
have they didn't deprive her of the
qualifications to do her job they just
exploited a weakness good thing I'll
take it I will totally take it
now Mark Lamont Hill has flip-flopped
Harvard has flip-flopped there's another
person flip-flopping these days it would
be the once future president of the
United States Chris Christie who is
saying he will not vote for Donald Trump
if he's nomin if it's Biden versus Trump
in the fall would you vote for Donald
Trump no so what is it about various
Republican candidates for the presidency
who live with the knowledge of what
Trump has done to the country the damage
that he's done to this country that will
ensue for God knows how long what is it
about them that causes them to just
kneejerk reaction oh yeah I'd vote for
Trump anyway it's it's an interesting
combination of two emotions uh Mike fear
and ambition so the fear part of it is
that all of them treasure um their
titles and so they treasure their titles
more than they treasure the honor that's
given to them by the people to actually
have those titles and they don't want
lose them and they're all worried about
being primaried by someone who would
have Donald Trump's endorsement that's a
yeah yeah no one's ever accused Chris
Christi of ambition or be the guy who
worked for Donald Trump after saying you
know he's a bad guy now he's a good guy
now I hate him again because Trump
pushed him out would you vote for him in
the fall
no but of
course the primary condition for being
considered to to debate in the
Republican primary debates was was a
pledge to say that you will support the
eventual nominee of the party and you
remember Donald Trump said I don't think
I'm going to sign that huh and and there
was this big Hollow Donald Trump he has
no loyalty to anyone but himself he's
destroying the Republican Party he's
just got unbridled ambition he's unored
from any principle he doesn't he's uh
hey you know what Trump was honest about
that all the rest of the candidates
signed it including Chris Christie and
then what happens Chris Christie's
campaign totally
collapses all of their campaigns
collapse other than Trump's which
remains strong and Chris they say okay
are you goingon to honor your pledge
goes no no I'm not no I'm a liar I'm an
ambitious liar and everything that we
accuse Donald Trump of we are all guilty
of to to to the 10th degree yeah no no
way it reveals these guys to lack the
what was supposed to be the
distinguishing feature between them and
Trump which was Integrity principle care
for the party ideological Mooring and
something solid but they don't have that
especially not Chris Christie perhaps
it's unfair to to say the same about the
other candidates certainly not Chris
Christie who was supposed to be the
chief Trump
antagonist anything anything you could
say about Donald Trump
any accusation that you could make
against him any insult you could throw
his way applies 100 times to Chris
Christie so it doesn't work so the
holier than thou campaign the
sanctimonious Campaign which is in part
why that that line that word that
nickname for Rond DeSantis while it
might not have been
fair for DeSantis himself and while it
might not have uh been the easiest to
roll off the tongue it's why it was a a
good choice of words to use against
Trump opponents broadly is because that
has been the chief
tool for the anti-trump campaigns going
back to 2016 the
sanctimony well this Trump he's a
Ruffian he's so immoral he's so terrible
he's so this that but consistently along
the way that's true of on the Republican
side and the Democrat side consistently
along the way we found out that Trump's
opponents don't don't often seem to
demonstrate much more principle than
than he has himself often they
demonstrate far less now turning to
the more likable presidential
contenders you got two people ahead of I
guess three people ahead of Chris chrisy
you got VI ramaswami but but VI and
Chris Christie's poll numbers are still
relatively low there are two people who
are a little further up even though
they're still far behind Trump that
would be Ronda santis and Nikki
Haley or now we might have to reverse
that because For the first time in a
national poll Nikki Haley has overtaken
Ronda sandz I said yesterday on the show
that for the first time in the RCP
average you had uh the the candidates
looking like they were tied for
second but now I said when when is one
of them going to to overtake the other
one well now you got out of 538 which is
a pretty respectable poll you now have
Nikki Haley as the second place
candidate there is a very real
possibility of a Nikki Haley nomin
and nobody believes this going back to
when she announced her candidacy
everyone wrote her off and laughed at
her and you know I hate to say I told
you so but some of us said hey hey hey
even if you don't like Nikki Haley even
if you think she's too um moderate or
something this is a an extraordinarily
talented politician who was able to
navigate very difficult Waters and and
appeal to The Establishment to the coke
Network to the moderates to the
centrists to Center left and to appeal
to Trump supporters she was a not only a
successful member of the Trump
Administration she was a particularly
popular member when she was the UN
Ambassador and when she left Trump gave
her a little a little short of a ticker
tape parade okay but they had a big
meeting lots of cameras Oh Nikki has
been great then Nikki turned on Trump
then she supported Trump again then she
turned on Trump and she's just navigated
the waters very very well don't forget
Trump has being indicted the libs are
going to do everything that they
possibly can to keep them off the ballot
totally unprecedented actions that
they've been doing since 2015
2016 using the federal government to spy
on his campaign trying to undermine his
entire Administration with bogus charges
cooked up by the FBI and the Democrats
impeaching him twice doesn't work then
accusing him of insurrection based on
nothing then throwing him off the using
a court to throw him off the ballot
using a secretary of state to throw him
off the ballot doing their very level
best to defend democracy by preventing
people from voting for the most popular
candidate they'll do anything they've
got they've got four indictments now you
know the only thing they've got left
after that is assassination and I don't
put it past them so the number two
person might matter because there is a
world even if Trump is the most popular
candidate and everybody in the world
wants to vote for him there is a world
in which the political order just does
not let him be the nominee which is why
the number two thing matters and could
be Nikki my favorite comment yesterday
is from first emperor who says anything
outside of meritocracy should be
absolutely rejected I say this is my
favorite comment because ailia man and
in most circumstances I agree I guess
but I I actually don't think that's a
liberal I don't think that's a
conservative perspective I think that's
kind of a liberal
perspective
because you don't really believe that I
don't really believe that that in all
cases every single thing in the whole
world should be
meritocracy I don't think so if you have
a pure
meritocracy then
you you don't have much care for people
who are a little slower people who are
disabled people who you don't you don't
really care for them you say well I
deserve exactly what I get CU I'm so
smart and fast and big and strong and
beautiful and you you you fall into a
kind of a dark view where where you
start to Value human beings more than
other human beings I don't like that uh
if you have a pure meritocracy you can't
have any inheritance from your parents I
don't think very conservative not not
that I come from you know a particularly
wealthy house household
but I I like the idea of inheritance
because it establishes some continuity
between the generations forget about
even monetary inheritance what about
cultural
inheritance those sorts of things that's
not just about a purely individualistic
meritocracy I think that's good what
about legacy admissions to schools I
wasn't a legacy admission to my college
but and I don't intend to send any of my
children to the college that I went to
but I like the idea of legacy admissions
because it creates affection for the
institution
because it encourages conservatism which
is a good thing so well I agree that our
current system of you know a racial cast
that discriminates against whites and to
a lesser degree Asians and that says
that men are the worst people on the
face of the Earth and I agree that
that's all extremely perverse and unjust
and meritocracy is preferable to that
but there is more to life than
meritocracy especially if you want to
conserve
anything Nikki haly now feeling pretty
good she's playing a win Nikki is trying
to get Trump to show up to the debate
she says with only three candidates
qualifying for the CNN debate it is time
for Donald Trump to show up as the
debate stage continues to shrink it's
getting harder for Donald Trump to
hide now she's saying three candidates
qualifying for the CNN debate because it
looks as though vake might not qualify
and this is because I don't know V is
alleging that it's because CNN is
changing the rules to keep him off the
stage and
frankly like probably V is a very
exciting candidate in this race he's
done much much better than anybody
expected him to do he his his entire
role in the race or big part of his role
in the race is to say things that the
political establishment does not want
you to say and and they can't even write
him off as some conspiracy theorist K
because he's smarter than all of them so
this is a guy this is one of the most
intelligent people in in the political
scene in the United States and he's
extremely well educated and he's
extremely accomplished and so they can't
just write him off and they can't even
call him some crank racist or whatever
because he's Indian so you know he's
he's very inconvenient for the political
establishment I don't put it past them
to try to to Torpedoes campaign but in
any case Nikki is saying okay the field
is shrinking we're going to get rid of
aake so Trump needs to
debate this call for Trump to debate
also seems to coincide with Trump saying
he would not pick Nikki Haley for his VP
so I said on the show a couple days ago
that uh with Nikki
surging she's saying she would pardon
Trump if Trump were convicted of crimes
and any of these ridiculous political
prosecutions Trump was saying some nice
things about Nikki Haley kind of
floating the idea that Nikki Haley could
be his running mate he needs a running
mate I don't know who it's going to be
right now and so I said okay the
question is are the Trump supporters
loyal enough to Trump blindly loyal
enough to Trump that they would tolerate
a Nicki haly vice presidency even as so
much of the Trump base appears to hate
Nikki Haley that's the question maybe it
could be like a bush Reagan kind of
thing fairly or unfairly Nikki Haley is
the representative of the establishment
right now that happened the moment she
took the coke Network money so and Trump
is the representative of the Insurgent
populist Wing the Paleo Wing the Trad
Wing what I don't know whatever whatever
label you want to throw on him he's not
from the bush Wing he's not from the
Romney wing of the party so maybe you
could have a Unity ticket like you had
in 1980 Reagan and Bush Reagan was the
conservative Bush was the The
Establishment guy and they unified and
they had a successful presidency could
you get that with with Haley but then
Trump came out and he said no I'm not
doing that she's a bird brain I don't
like her you know all the typical Trump
insults so now Nikki is going after
him still I think Nikki's playing her
cards very smart but still Trump has no
incentive to
debate he I think he came out and said
that he if if the election got close he
would
debate but right now even as the field
is shrinking even as support is
consolidating behind you would say Haley
and DeSantis increasingly looking more
like Haley than DeSantis but who knows
we there still hasn't been a vote cast
in a caucas or primary uh still Trump is
how many dozens of points above them you
know it's just not close enough there's
still no incentive and the only way
you're going to get Trump to debate is
if there is a political incentive for
him to do it right now if he shows up to
the debate it's all downside no upside
he's dominating the field everywhere so
he can only
lose and Trump knows that and he's not
going to play to
lose the rest of the GOP is
consolidating as well so you got the
primary field consolidating but now you
got the endorsements consolidating this
started a few weeks ago you had started
actually months ago but the really
kicked up a few weeks ago you had people
who had endorsed other candidates
notably Ronda santis starting to flip
and to endorse Donald Trump you had some
other high ranking Republicans come out
even Kevin McCarthy the ousted uh leader
of the Republicans in the house he said
oh yeah I'm supporting Trump you know
Josh Holly yeah I'm supporting Trump
guys who had been kind of on the fence
they're going now Steve scales who is
the House Majority Leader is's a number
two Republican in the country he came
out he said I'm proud to endorse Donald
Trump for president in 2024 and I look
forward to working with Trump and a
republican House and Senate to fight for
those families who are struggling under
the weight of Biden's failed policies
okay why is scales doing this is he's
the most rockr Trump supporter in the
world no it's because he sees the
writing on the wall that's what this is
about and
so as uh Ernest Hemingway said of
bankruptcy it happens gradually then
suddenly a line that Drew claven liked
to quote and then I like to quote and
then you know like every conservative
quotes now uh
every conservative is is going to feel
this pull I'm not saying they're going
to do it but they're going to feel this
pull to endorse Trump particularly as
the attacks against him from the
prosecutors ramp up
now well you know I'm something of a
tease and today is theology Thursday
which you'll get in the member block if
you're not a member you got to go on
over to dailywire.com And subscribe and
use code nolles and you'll you'll uh
have a great time in the crem de La
Creme but there's a story I don't have
time to get to today about how a
Michigan State
Representative is proposing stripping
tax exemption from the Satanic Temple
which you're going to hear some civil
Libertarians and the secularists are
going to go up in arms about this oh no
this is terrible it's actually a pretty
good idea in principle but but there's
some problems with it we'll get to it
tomorrow perhaps the rest of the show
continues now become a member use code
nolles
can use code nolles wle at check out for
2 months free on all annual
[Music]
plans